you know when i was in kiev in ukraine i
was there to moderate the first lady's
summit of first ladies and gentlemen and
in the middle of it a guy came on in
combat fatigues i assumed he was
military it turned out he wasn't at all
his name is fedor uh shandor fedia
shandle he's the head of a sociology
faculty at a university in kiev and a
historian he's with the territorial
defense in the haku region
and he actually has gone in and enlisted
to fight on the front line he came back
from the front line to talk of the
summit here was me talking to about the
summit when i discovered this
i don't think i've i've ever interviewed
anybody who
sits on a panel one minute and literally
is going back to trenches to fight for
his country it's an amazing thing my
duty in peaceful time to teach
it's my main line of duty in the war
time my line of duty is protecting my
family and my
nation thank you
it's amazing
well it was amazing and then even more
amazingly i got this video from him back
on the front line take a look
hello peers
uh today is uh 24 july
it's my soldier's brother khlobsi for
mahayana
maybe three four kilometer of zero line
deadline
slaviansk
region
hello nice to meet you
the guy's a university lecturer isn't
that incredible
out there fighting risk country
uh very close to the front line there so
to feder shandor and your guys in that
trench best of luck to you we're all
behind you well joining me now is
tonight's pierce back to all tv
contributors to cracker political
journalist ava's and tina and social and
political commentator i mean that's a
polite way of putting it ann coulter
welcome to all of you oh it's called
welcome across the pond what brings you
to this country and why wasn't i warm
i thought i'd stage a sneak attack on
you and here i am uh no i love london
i'm so happy here it's a beautiful city
please take care of it let me ask you
about ukraine because there is you know
there's a growing sentiment in america
that with recession
really pretty much here now surging
living costs and so on that america
shouldn't be committing so much money to
helping fight a war which some americans
feel have to do with them zalensky's
answer to that was actually this is a
war everyone is involved in it's
affecting everybody what's your view
um i don't think so i mean you're not
going to like my answer but that was my
position from the beginning and then
very rarely like anything becomes out of
your mouth
oh it is definitely moving that
direction it wasn't at first it was just
you know endless endless coverage for
this i mean there are a lot of things i
could say about this going back to
i mean i think putin is a monster you
don't go around invading other countries
but we did provoke him putin has been
reaching out to america he was the first
person to call after 9 11 to express his
condolences to american bush doesn't
even call him back we have just so
dissed the russians for such a long time
and the nato thing i'm sorry i'm with
noam chomsky pap buchanan george cannon
once the soviet union fell there's no
point to nato and we keep encroaching
encroaching well actually we're now
seeing exactly what the point of nato is
well you could stop a murderer
that's what nato is there for no if he
tries to invade a nato country he will
get attacked it's not a nato country he
doesn't want to become a nato country
and no i'm sorry the ukraine was
historically part of the russian empire
of influence and i'm not defending
including the soviet union
no i am not what are you saying but why
let's get back to the main point why
should americans care about this we have
our own problems why should the british
care about it i mean you guys well i
don't need i think it's a beautiful city
and i hope you save it but you've just
passed brexit a huge part of which was i
think this is the same reason when we
have more immigrants coming in i am so
glad that that's not pivot to impact
your guy
boris is gone right and hopefully the
next one will actually fulfill the
promises of brexit but how about let me
something [ __ ]
here's my point to you when we were
attacked by the nazis and when this city
was attacked in the way that uh
ukraine's leaders being attacked
actually the americans when you were
attacked at mohammed realized it was a
world war and you came and helped us win
the war and defeat nazis or we'd all be
speaking german and that's the reason
why when you have a massive war in
europe like this which is the biggest
since world war ii that's why we should
come together and america whether you
like it or not biggest superpower in the
world
we need your help ukraine needs your
help you can't compare everything to
hitler okay i can't compare people
okay hitler and babies pearl harbor i'll
be interested but he's not attacking the
united states you've been listening to
this with calmness well no i don't know
i think you were just talking quite a
lot of tripe actually but i mean that's
that's your your thing and
you know when you talk about um russia
not you know putin not actually
affecting the rest of the world has
nothing to do with america it's nothing
to do with britain britain right now is
facing a huge crisis in terms of grain
we physically can't get wheat into the
country this winter we're looking at our
energy bills are going to be something
like 500 pounds a month it does affect
us it directly does affect us but you
know we talk about globalization most of
your products probably half of what
you're wearing has come from different
parts of the world it's totally obscene
to think that we're going to go back to
some sort of like you know fdr like why
not roll down what's going on in
swaziland a lot of countries are having
a lot of problems and not all of your
energy problems or grain problems are
coming from the invasion do you actually
know
your interview with him i mean i think
the most
disturbing point was i'm glad you asked
him are you willing to give up anything
here and no his position is why should
they give up anything because what he
was going to fight to the last time
somebody invaded the united
states any part of america right you're
telling me that a single american would
say oh yeah we'll give him a bit of land
whoever it is
you would you would come together and
drive them out of your country okay by
the way you'd want us to help people
could we google something russia has
what 50 times more people than ukraine
you got to end this war or it's going to
be down to the last ukraine
i'm rarely speechless but i think in
this instance i'm quite speechless i
think the
international repercussions of what is
happening in ukraine cannot be
understated at the moment the russian
foreign minister is in africa because he
realizes that you know people have
forgotten this but many africans are
dying with the rising cost of energy and
wheat for instance egypt which is the
largest importer of reach the price of
which has gone up by 250 percent i think
it's irresponsible to think that what is
happening in ukraine isn't affecting
everyone including americans um and it's
only going to get worse i mean
look the us is trying to find a way
around that um at the moment but i i
just don't understand how you can think
that's this is not an american problem
it clearly is and he's not going to stop
at ukraine moldova is next then
lithuania then estonia then latvia would
give it all back to him if he wants he
must have restored the soviet union yeah
vladimir help yourself far more
preposterous than the idea that he's
going to
forget pearl harbor that he's going to
continue okay when he continues maybe
maybe we can but you know what else
affects the rest of the world whether
the united states america of america
remains the united states of america why
don't you guys come over and help us
build our wall why don't you help us
deal with crime because you're right we
do step in we we send grain food we take
out warlords i mean you guys do too but
america is
mostly a force for good in the entire
world and our country is crumbling right
now so yes everything has an effect i'm
not saying there's no effect and you can
make your six degrees of separation
saving the united states of america i
think saving britain is more important
than what is happening in rwanda
swaziland or ukraine
okay let's move on to the issue of the
torah leadership race because actually
whoever wins this race is going to have
to make these kind of calculations and
there will be people in this country who
also think we shouldn't be spending a
lot of money on a war in ukraine when we
have so many problems here and they may
not do the the points of detail which
bring the things together and connect
connect the dots here from what you've
seen with liz trust and richie suena who
do you trust more of the two of them one
of them will be prime minister to
actually do the right calls on this kind
of thing whichever one employs ben
wallace as their defense secretary i
think he's the only one who's actually
been holding it together i don't think
either of them have got a clue i don't
think there's ukraine much disagreement
there i don't see any of them sort of
getting rid of ben wallace um but i
think it's clear that rishi sunak's
campaign is in free fall um and i think
the biggest issue he's had has been
communication
boris said a cheeky made a cheeky remark
today that he suddenly found the money
to
cut vat on energy bills um which he
actually refused to do beforehand and he
hasn't really explained sort of his
stance on
it's kind of flip-flopping isn't it yeah
it's gonna be it's look we've got five
weeks left uh i'm actually off from
today i'll be back on the day they
announced the new prime minister and i
would say at the moment this trust is
playing a better political game yeah
that rishi is saying that probably
assumed he's gonna win this quite easily
not so easy now at all but it's two
shades of the same color right right do
you care who wins that or not um yes
esther told me who's the guy i like
reese mog yeah
oh my god
all right
you know what there's always a low
moment with ankle for an interview we've
just reached it wonderful from a very
low bar by the way uh it's good to see
you and you know thank you as always
you've rattled everybody's cage
tomorrow
really good to see
you